what does it feel like to be back in st
louis for the u.s chess championships
well it's great i mean i
i won the u.s championship in 2018 and
you know then i i didn't defend the
title in 2019 that was the only
classical us championship since then so
i feel like i've only missed one uh it's
been a while since i won now because we
had the pandemic so things sort of shut
down but i'm really looking forward to
being back yeah it feels great um didn't
feel like too long ago i was uh here
playing rapping and blitz and sing photo
cups so yeah it's nice to be back yeah
it's i mean i've i've been playing all
summer in st louis but this is a special
event it's been a long time since i've
won the title here so i'm really hoping
that i'm gonna be able to do that this
year yeah i'm really excited to play
another u.s championship i
not sure how many i played already but
it's been a lot and obviously uh last
year i missed playing over the board oh
it's really exciting i mean i haven't
been here in two years uh where i played
a classic
and through throughout the pandemic it's
all been online chess
well it's great
especially since last year we had to
play online
and it wasn't classical chess it wasn't
in person
so it felt much different and i had a
great tournament personally in 2019 and
i had the best memories of this
tournament so i'm
really excited to to be back to normal
it's great it's
my first u.s championships that actually
happened in person i played last year
which was online
but in person it's the first my first uh
challenges so it feels great uh well
it's very good i i was in saint louis
studying at webster university but
you know this is my first time in the
clubs in over 18 months so pretty pretty
cool
i'm really excited i mean i've been here
a lot i was here in july for the u.s
junior but u.s championship is something
new to me i've never played this
tournament before and
i'm sure i'll really enjoy it i always
like playing at the chess club and
obviously this is the biggest tournament
in the us so i'm just really happy to be
here well it's a great surprise for me
i mean i i live here very close so it's
my
city right now where i live with my
family
it's a pleasure for me to to be here and
play is such a great tournament saint
louis really feels like home to me so
this one determines i really look
forward it's a very tough tournament
don't get me wrong
there are a lot of lower rated players
so just to protect your ranking it's
very difficult and they're very young
and ambitious also well it's it's
amazing it's a great honor this was
completely unexpected of course i'm the
wild card and
you know i was
cleaning doing some menial tasks and all
of a sudden i get the invite on my phone
so i knew from that very second that i
was gonna play um obviously i'm a little
bit out of practice it's gonna be an
uphill climb but
it's amazing to be here and it's an
honor i'm going to try to do everybody
proud